president trump has continued to make
claims about voter fraud
even saying the election would be stolen
in nevada and it's an issue the i-team
has been reporting on
vanessa murphy is live in the newsroom
tonight here at six o'clock with more
for us vanessa
well denise you can report suspected
voter fraud on the secretary of state's
website here but as the i-team has been
reporting election officials and
leaders in law enforcement have been
telling us
voter fraud is rare but if they receive
credible allegations
they will investigate them now i talked
with
deputy secretary of state of elections
wayne thorley on wednesday and
asked him about voter fraud and leading
up to the election
i talked with both the fbi and the u.s
postal inspection about it here's what
they told the i-team
any evidence of voter fraud in nevada so
far
no evidence whatsoever of
coordinated widespread
voter fraud we have
received a handful of complaints with
some allegations
again they're just allegations at this
point unproven
that we're looking into but no no
evidence
of voter fraud i wouldn't say it's
widespread
i would say that we get reports every
year every election cycle
of potential voter fraud situations and
we investigate them thoroughly
and we hold the people if it's uh if
it's
proven then we hold them accountable
through the u.s attorney's office as of
right now i am unaware of any
incredible reports of any voter fraud
being committed through the mail
on wednesday when i asked thorley to
specify a number about how many
allegations of voter fraud were being
investigated
he said less than 10 i also want to
mention i reached out to the department
of justice
today to find out about any
investigations into voter fraud
here and i did not hear back now we've
also heard concerns about
how to check whether your mail ballot
was received or counted
there are two websites where you can do
that we'll put both of them at
eightnewsnow.com here's a look
at one of them but keep in mind ballots
are still being counted so even though
it was received
there still may be time for it to be
counted again
reporting live vanessa murphy 8 news now